[Music]
sherry is in kansas city hi sherry
welcome to the ramsay show
hi there thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
i have a 22 year old son who was in an
apprentice program getting paid so no
college debt but and he's going to be
finishing that program in about a year
looking ahead and he's working or he
would be the one calling you i'm looking
ahead he's wanting to know
what you suggest and how he built credit
because
right now he has
none because
he hasn't purchased anything
he's purchased something he just didn't
use debt
that's correct he's always paid cash
and he asked you to ask us
did he come to you wondering about this
he did because we've he's grown up with
with um dave ramsey and and knowing the
knowledge behind it because his parents
we live by it so
well what are your thoughts on how to
build credit or if it's wise too
well i don't know that's why i called
you because we didn't start using dave
ramsey until we were almost 30 years old
and going by his plan so by that time
we'd already established credit through
purchasing a house and um a credit card
um
i'm confused which dave ramsey you've
been following
because this dave ramsey never told you
to build your fico score or build credit
we told you to get out of that and stay
out of debt does that sound familiar
yes correct i'm saying that we were at
that point and then we met you and i
know but you said your son grew up with
dave ramsey and his first question is
how to build credit but so he must have
missed something
well other than knowing to just save and
that's what he's doing
um
but we don't know
i mean okay
you'll be saving for a long time sure
and so we just wanted to know
our recommendations so the way i was
raised at 22 i thought the same thing
and i was like i got to build my score
that's that's how you live your
financial life and what we found is that
the best way to build the financial
future for your son is without a credit
score at all and that's very
counter-cultural that's very against the
grain but he's already done it by paying
cash for school and so the question is
you only need
does he need a credit score if he's not
going to take out any more debt
and that's the only reason why people
really build their credit score is so
that they can have a high score so that
they can take on more debt and so if
he's already on board with the ramsey
plan of living his life without debt
then he can do all of the things that
everyone else can do and he can do it
without a credit score and that includes
he's going to pay cash for a car
therefore he doesn't need a credit score
because he doesn't need a car loan he
can do manual underwriting when it comes
time for him to buy a house which means
they're not going to look at his credit
score they're going to look at his
overall financial picture and you can
get a mortgage without a credit score
and so really everything else you're
paying cash for and so you don't need a
credit score the purpose of the credit
score is to get you in debt so that you
can get more in debt so that you can get
more in debt and you need to build up
your score
precisely out of the 10 000 millionaires
that we surveyed and asked them how they
became a millionaire the number that
said
that they became millionaires because of
their great credit or great credit score
was precisely zero
and so building the credit score is not
a goal that we would teach you
we would teach you to avoid debt pay
cash for things
and um
you know if you're going to get a
mortgage it's the only time we don't
yell at you for debt uh because it
because all the other debt is
prohibiting you from winning and really
the mortgage is too but at least you can
get it paid off at least it's going up
in value
and so um you know that's the one thing
but other than that so the answer is i
would not build my credit score i would
not worship at the altar of the great
fico it turns out he is not a very good
provider as a god
that's for sure yeah and sherry i've got
a resource for you if you go look up the
fine print podcast you can go to
fineprintpodcast.com
let your son listen to the episode that
we did titled the dirty truth behind
your credit score we dig into this it's
short it's enjoyable he'll have a great
time and it will unpack why we say you
don't need a credit score and we'll show
him how to do all of those things and
it's by george and so it's a lot nicer
than me
and so you're going to like it
he'll enjoy it thank you for admitting
that i'm nicer than you well it's not a
heart attack america has been waiting
for this most people are nicer than me
um i'm actually really nice because i'm
really telling you what you need to go
when because i love you but i just uh it
hurts to hear i took a little shot i
don't really put much
icing on it
so it's just the cake okay so
but um and i'm kind of in a hurry
because there's a lot of people that
need this help so that that's just makes
me get to the point
in 30 years of doing this it's just you
know okay there you go that's what you
need to do and so there it is and yeah
yeah but so yeah go listen to the fine
print by the way all the episodes of
fine print was robin hood but the last
one of the last the last one the last c
or the first season and now we're gonna
do another season and we've got it now
we're thinking maybe uh time share
episode oh yeah reverse mortgages
conversion mortgage episode oh scams
we've got to do scam scams there's so
many real i mean for real scams we talk
about a lot of things that are the same
as a scam but like real people that get
scammed and real scams artists out there
those that's a really good episode
that'll be good we chose a podcast where
there's endless amounts of content so
that's good there's always ways people
are getting screwed when it comes to
money that's true that's true so the
fine print one of the ramsey network
well the ramsey network's newest podcast
and very popular by the way
it's done really well george i
appreciate that well thanks for all of
you who listen out there